وقال الجيش الاوكراني انه احرز التقدما
جديدا على محور باخموت واوضح الجيش
الاوكراني انه يواصل الهجوم في محور
الجنوبي باتجاه مدينه ميلوتوبل
تطورات المدنيه اذا نتابعها من زابولوجيا
مع مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام تقدم في
باخمت وهجوم مستمر في محور ما الذي تحقق
حتى الان
بالفعل زين وهذا ربما ما يدفع القوات
الروسيه الى فتح جبهات اخرى على امتداد
اقليم الدومباز وتحديدا في منطقه دونيتسك
حيث جاء قبل قليل بان القوات الجويه
الروسيه اغارت على مصنع الفحم الحجري في
منطقه
وهو احد اكبر مصانع الفحم الحجري في
اوروبا عموما وهنالك حريق كبير اندلع في
هذا المصنع الهام والحيوي في منطقه التي
يقول الجيش الاوكراني انه يصد يوميا عشرات
الهجمات التي يشنها الجيش الروسي في تلك
المنطقه في محاوله لاختراق الحصون التي
اقامها الجيش الاوكراني في تلك المنطقه
والتي يبدو انها ما زالت عصيه على القوات
الروسيه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب اذن النيران
الان تشتعل في هذا المصنع الحيوي
والمسؤولون في المصنع يقولون بان الق
الروسيه تتعمد توجيه هذه الضربات المنشات
الصناعيه في اقليم دومباس وتحديدا في
هذا الهجوم على افريكا ياتي بعد اعلان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بانها احرز
التقدما على محوري مدينه باخموت تحديدا
عند بلده شوميز واودره ديفيكا
وهذا ياتي ايضا بعد ايام من تمكن القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه من اعاده السيطره على
بلدتيك لشيفكا واندريه في المحور الجنوبي
لباقمت وتوسيع دائره النيران هناك بعد ان
كانت مركزه فقط في المناطق الشماليه
لباخ صحيح بان القوات الاوكرانيه توسع
حلقه النيران حول القوات الروسيه في تلك
المنطقه وتشتت ربما العمليات
وتجعلها ممتده على مسافه كبيره لكن الوصول
الى ضخمه يبدو انه ما زال بعيد بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه التي تسعى على الاقل من
الناحيه المعنويه لتحقيق هذا الهدف
واستعاده ضخمه التي تكبد فيها الجيش
الروسي خسائر كبيره
بالعتاد والارواح والجيش الاوكراني يقول
بانه سيطر ناريا على الطريق السريع بين
جورليسكا وباخمت هذا الطريق الذي كان يعد
طريقا حيويا لامدادات الجيش الروسي في
باخموت من الجهه الجنوبيه هذا على الصعيد
اقليم الدومباس هنا في زبالوجيا جنوب
المحور الملتهب عند
ما زال على حاله معارك شرسه كما يبدو
والجيش الاوكراني الذي تحدث في الاسابيع
الماضيه عن انه سيطر على بلده رابوتين في
هذا المحور الهجومي والهجومي المعاكس يقول
بانه خاض بالامس قتالا مع القوات الروسيه
التي حاولت استعاده معاقلها ومواقعها عند
روبوتين وهذا يؤكد زين بان يؤكد على بطئ
الحركه وبطئ هذا الهجوم في تلك
المنطقه من
مراسله الجزيره شكرا جزيلا لك